what's up this is tim sykes here i am
here with these guys on ice coffee hour
this is the 25th ever episode
we have made 12 418
in adsense so far that's an incredible
intro you nailed it
that was good i'm pumped
this is the first time i think we've had
to do that with no cuts at all yeah your
life is you gave me you told me what to
say but it's crazy that i started with
twelve thousand four hundred fifty
dollars like that
i literally thought you were talking
about my bio when you said that number
and i was like
no this is hilarious it's a little crazy
so i've mentioned this to you before so
this is a cool podcast because now we've
been in
three jubilee episodes together yeah so
that's how we met
but i actually found you i was like 13
years old
i think 13 or 14 years old i had just
got a laptop my first ever laptop and i
got
really into the stock trading penny
stocks and it was through
you that got me into trading penny
stocks in the very beginning three well
good and bad
good and bad so i started i scrounged up
all the money i had
and i doubled my money yeah in like a
few months
then you got it i lost i i lost pretty
much all of it
what happens that's what happens without
rules this is why i teach
yeah so how much money did you make if
you're under 18 by the way get parental
proof yeah so i think i started with
like
gosh i used all the money i had saved
like maybe it was like a thousand
fifteen hundred bucks i can't remember
somewhere around there
and then i i basically just went in like
random penny stocks
and i thought i knew what i was doing
and i doubled i i think i made like
1500 or two grand on that and i was so
excited about that i'd wake up before
school i trade
stocks and i go to school there was
wi-fi there and i tried to trade
during class and they would catch me and
then yeah i just i had a series of just
bad trades where one of them i lost
because i would go all
in and out so i was thinking like i'd go
all the way i'm paying attention to my
lessons
i say never go all in rule number one is
cut losses i wanted to make money
because i remember
your your tagline what was it yeah you
you went from
12 grand into 2 million before i
graduated college that was it
but i always cut losses quickly i got
cocky once upon a time too
so 500 grand yeah so your loss was how
did how did you learn
well hold on real quick we got to make
sure we have a proper introduction all
right cool
so tim sykes you are a stock trader
slash youtuber and jubilee participant
teacher traveler philanthropist there
you go youtube is
a little down the list for me but i
tried to just get my lessons out
and i should have taught you more i'm
sorry i didn't reach you in time
you know but this is the thing 90 of
traders lose so
even though now i've actually made
roughly 6 million in trading i donate
all my trading profits to charity
i show my screen you can see me you know
doing my thing and seeing what charts i
like
but rule number one is cutting losses
quickly ninety percent of traders lose
it's probably like ninety three percent
i tried and i lost you're you're typical
i wasn't i wasn't being greedy though
like i had my
i had my set percentage profits that i
was shooting for every day and i just
never hit them but it's just not an
exact science but
also 2020 is crazy were you trading this
year or no it was last it was a it was
about a year and a half no it's probably
a year and a half two so the market in
2020 is crazy like i made nearly a
million dollars this year last year i
only made like 125
000 trading it's like 10 times as much
this year so
you know not all years are created equal
but it's also not an exact science too
like you can set your 15
goal the market doesn't care what your
goal is it might just rise seven percent
then you got to adapt
so it's like teaching an inexact science
got it which is very
difficult like if you're a math teacher
5 7 always equals 12.
but for me i'm like no if the mark is
different five plus seven can equal 14.
and people are just like
what all right let's slow it down yeah
okay let's take
let's let's slow it down how many how
much iced coffee have you had today
i'm pumped up i'm pumped up i've had i
didn't even drink coffee like the past
few years the past like two years the
fastest people told you you need to stop
drinking coffee
no i gotta drink more i gotta up it
drinking you know today anti-energy
and not any energy so this is bryce hall
he's like one of my
like youtube friends okay tick tock tick
tock guys he has any energy so i was
drinking that today
i've never had it before so i'm a little
more what's in it i don't know we'll
find out
we'll see we'll see how he sells an
energy drink or what is it yeah any
energy
he just he like him and his friends like
just started they gave me bryce hall
is a tech talker yeah teenagers need
more energy that's the thing like i
remember how much energy i had when i
was like 18 or 19 compared to now
yeah i did not need more energy i do
because i'm
just working so much harder there's so
many more stocks i you know i have many
more students this year so i'm just like
trying to keep up
it's a good problem to have yeah so
let's talk about your journey
okay from the beginning until the end
give us the
give us the summary there is no end but
um
no so my parents gave me control of my
bar mitzvah money twelve thousand four
hundred and fifteen dollars
that's a lot of bar mitzvah so i got
i think that's a great way to make money
you know my mom is jewish
so technically that makes me jewish your
mom's jewish she is
so is mine yeah i think it's a good way
but i you know i was a tennis player and
my grandfather was like responsible for
half of it he offered me a tennis court
or cash and i was like
cash okay like doubled it it would have
been like six grand okay um but i had
surgery on my arm i had tommy john
surgery so i couldn't play tennis i had
the 12 grand sitting like series ee bond
senior year of high school
my parents gave me control of it
thinking like i would lose it all in the
stock market but i was like no i'm
obsessed
i started really focusing on different
charts yeah um back then
you know when i first got started this
was 1999 2000 i'm old
but how did you learn because so this is
what i'm getting into so back then you
had dial up internet nothing
like would load fast i would skip
classes i was already into college early
admission
i would make friends with the librarian
go to the library bank you know like
where there's like
12 computers in a row right so i would
load one web page on one computer and
while i was loading i would go to
another so i was like
kind of crazy mad scientist loading
different web pages and making friends
with a librarian so that i could
research but i learned it all the hard
way
and you know i was there at the right
place at the right time 99 2000 you
could be an idiot and still make money
um you're just buying any stock that
goes up were you looking into
candlestick charts or what was your
how would you pick stock so at first i
was an investor but i was
my account was going nowhere for like
three months was like 12 400 12
600 12 200 and i was like this is
terrible and i'm sitting there with two
casts
on my arm i can't play tennis i can't
really do anything but i can type
um so i gravitated towards lower price
penny stocks which the whole world hates
because of jordan belfort because he
scammed
the entire generation but those kinds of
sketchy companies can double or triple
in a day
so back in 99 and 2000 the hottest
companies were netscape
yahoo i couldn't afford those stocks
they were like trading at like 60 70 100
a share i wanted you know smaller
companies so i gravitated towards these
little piece of crap penny stocks
and they would spike 50 100 200 i would
never go all in
but i would put in like three or four
grand and try to make like a grand on a
on the trade
so i take a piece of my account and take
a piece of the move
and i do that over and over again i was
so lucky i say i'm like jewish forest
gump
like back in 99 and 2000 i was
piggybacking these boiler rooms i didn't
know about boiler rooms no one knew
about them until they got exposed in
2001
but i was just buying these penny stock
breakouts and i was like this works
almost every time this is like magic
what i didn't know is that boiling rooms
were calling naive financial people at
dinner time
the beginning of like telemarketing yeah
pitching them on these penny stocks
and they would put in their buy order at
the market open the next day and the
prices would bid up
15 20 so i would buy these stocks that
showed the right pattern at like 3 40 3
45 pm eastern
market closes at 4 pm eastern they get
the telemarketing call at 6 p.m
they put the buy order in at 9 30 and
i'm selling into the people who are
getting marketed at night
how did you find those stocks so i've
always just looked at big percent gainer
stocks that are up
15 20 30 50 100 in the day um every
stock has like an amazing story but
they're almost all full of crap so for
me
i just want to make sure that they're in
play so that's why 2020 is so crazy
because
i'm trading hand sanitizer stocks i'm
trading vaccine stocks
electric vehicle stocks whatever sector
is hot but back then
i had inadvertently piggybacked on the
boiler rooms calling the
people at like dinner time so i was in
the stock
before the boiler rooms were calling
okay and i didn't know i was just
following the paper so how long were you
making money from that
so senior year of high school i made
about a hundred grand off my 12 grand
which was a lot you know i'm from a
small town in connecticut
um okay did you did you lose money
because yeah
it's when you say like you had 12 grand
and then senior year
like how long were you trading before
that how long did it take for you to
learn
and equip yourself with the technique so
three months i was
i my investments were going nowhere and
i was boring and then i gravitated and i
got lucky with this pattern it was
literally within three months and within
six months i had made a hundred grand
and i wasn't winning every time but it
was winning like 90 to 95 percent of
time
you have to understand the companies
were scams they were getting calls
about boiler rooms like boiler rooms
were pitching and stuff how did that
work
explain the boiler room i mean i love
the wolf of wall street
right right so they're calling out
people this is i mean wolf wall street
is pre-internet but telemarketing was
the same thing
so they call up people at dinner time
like hey um we've got this great company
i got your name off this list but you
know i have this great pick
the stock's trading at two bucks a share
but they have such a great technology
it should be worth like fifty dollars a
share and the people at home they're
like no no they're about to hang up but
then the boiler room operator is trying
to market
and pump it up saying like this has
great potential just give me a chance i
want to be like
you know it's everything in the wolf of
wall street um so give me a chance so
they buy 5 000 shares
and again because they're calling at
dinner time the buy order doesn't go in
until the next market open at 9 30 a.m
when the market opens
so for me i didn't know anything about
the board of rooms no one knew anything
i just saw stocks going up into the
clothes and i was like huh
when they go up into their clothes a
certain percentage like 20 30 percent
when they're a low price stock
they usually gap up the next day so
when all the people who got called at
dinnertime would put in their buy orders
just trusting their telemarketers who
called them those buy orders would stack
up and the stock would gap up 15
20 and i would sell so i'd buy at 3 40 3
45 p.m in the afternoon
sell at like 9 30 2 a.m the next morning
so when the people were buying stocks
after hours were they just buying it
markets during market orders
but if they call it dinner time yeah and
they place an order is that just a
market order the next day so they're
going to pay
a premium like 20 exactly and that's the
thing so that you're seeing market
orders this is another thing
like robinhood these days right now so
part of the reason why 2020 is
so much like 2000 robin hood the
brokerage right uses market orders
so everyone gets all excited around 9 30
a.m all the robin hood buy orders right
now in 2020 are piling up at 9 30 a.m
and the stock explodes between 9 30 and
9 35 as all the robin hooders
so how does after hours trading work
because i've done that with like tesla
stocks
got a little bit after hours it posts
how does it lock in that price
so back in 1999 2000 and now i mean
i trade a lot of penny stocks they don't
trade after hours so all the orders pile
up it's like a powder keg right at 9 30
a.m eastern
so tesla amazon apple they all trade
like until 8 pm eastern so if there's
news at like 5 p.m 6 p.m you can still
trade it until 8 pm
um and you can actually get up early in
the morning you can trade it at like 4
a.m if you really want to get no sleep
the next day
but with penny stocks the stock closes
at 4 pm eastern
whatever happens between 4 pm eastern
and 9 30 a.m eastern doesn't matter how
many buy orders or sell orders
everything gets executed right around 9
30. got it so there's a chance though
that everyone
wants to sell after 100 and then it gaps
way lower correct
so that happens sometimes like one time
i slept in because it didn't work 100
of the time but you know sometimes like
to boil the room you know maybe they
didn't make their calls maybe they got
rated by the fbi or something so the
calls weren't made and one time i slept
in in the stock dropped 50
and i lost like 18 grand there's nothing
i could do it was just
well this didn't work got it so you made
100 grand
by high school what senior year of high
school
what did you spend that on nothing i
didn't take anything out because i was
too focused on trading and then freshman
year in college i made about 700 grand
so i parlayed that 12 grand into over
700 grand same pattern
just taking bigger positions i'll tell
you one my favorite pattern
freshman year in college i couldn't even
like get into bars i had like three fake
ids taken away from me i'm like so
skinny now i have the reverse problem
now i eat like
a celery and i gained like 30 pounds but
back then i could eat like anything and
i was so
thin and like it just looked weak but i
was trading these stocks and so
it wasn't just boiler rooms again i
focus on these patterns like
when will there be a lot of buy orders
piling up at the market open
so i was stupid kind of like you like in
the beginning i was like aggressive
and i put in when i had made a quarter
of a million dollars i put in 175 000
in one stock over the weekend yeah this
company said that they um
could cure uh back then like you had
cell phone fuzziness problems like you
had us
it wasn't even like a cell phone it was
like it was like a cord it was like
old-school cell phones and there was
fuzziness
and they came up with this whole
scientific explanation we can
fix the fuzziness problem and you know
whether or not it worked there were no
exposes back in 2000
they came out with a press release on
friday saying hey we were just
interviewed by this tv crew
it's going to air on sunday during the
week because the the
people were excited about the technology
not a boiler room just technology
the stock had gone from five to 17. so
it had already tripled
in one week i put in 10 000 shares
because i was an idiot just being
aggressive i was like well they said
they were on tv
it's got to be positive sure enough it
was positive on sunday
i thought i could just sell the 10 000
shares at like 20
make like 30 grand but instead because
of all the buy orders piling up at the
market open on monday
because the tv was so positive i ended
up selling it around 29 and locking in
120 grand in profits wow that was my
biggest profit ever
at that time and i was like i'm thinking
to myself like i can't do anything and
i'm like downloading illegal movies on
merc
and i'm making a hundred grand plus in a
day and the thing i didn't even have to
sell it i was like so
worried about you know selling it right
near the market open
it didn't even matter it spiked up to 50
the next day and what about taxes
did you take into account taxes back
then so i always just you know have an
accountant um he's actually been with me
since the beginning and i just
pretty much paid like 40 35 to 40 got it
yeah
okay questions you have jack yeah so at
that time you weren't spending any money
it was basically all being
correct and and i remember i went to red
lobster once to celebrate and i ordered
like
extra lobsters that was my one
celebration excellent how many pounds
how many pounds
a lot that was the beginning of when i
started eating too much i don't know
lobster is so good that's my one food i
purposely don't treat myself to lobster
because it's so good i wanted to still
be special really
i got in a fight with my rabbi because i
was like i love lobsters and lobsters
not kosher and i'm like
i'm jewish it's just tastes like butter
to me no
i love butter dude game over
it tastes like crab and it tastes like
butter it's just like
rare lobster used to do on tuesdays it
was like all you can eat king crab
tuesdays
i don't know if you remember this so my
dad and i would go right when
we're you know what it used to be frugal
too right so like we would go right when
they opened at 5 30 we'd eat as much
crap as we could
we're full by like 6 30 then we just sit
there right
and we're like drinking water like we're
like just chilling and they're like
the waitresses are like confused but
then we're going ready for round two
until like seven years i used to do that
there you see there's a casino in
california where every
i think it was a tuesday or a thursday
night they had all you could eat lobster
buffet yes
and so we would get there i think at
like 4 p.m when they open yeah
and just stay there until about nine
it's fantastic and you just keep eating
and keep eating keep eating i think it
was like 40 bucks
yeah but i would eat like 200 or the
lobster no it's fantastic
i got paid basically to go and eat
lobster i did in florida there was
another restaurant that had
all-you-can-eat lobster and i had a
competition against one of my friends
his name is russell and we're going back
and forth
i did 13 and a half lobsters because
they were cut in half
oh man i was like i was like but that
was just but they said but those are
little tiny ones i mean it's got to be
like there were so many
there were no no no they were
regulations so it's like a pound and a
half minimum
right you get into like these eight
thirteen and a half
but but here's the but they actually
need itself tons of
lobster but it's like the shells yes i
still had a lot it was i don't recommend
13 and a half so i would say it's got to
be an
eighth so whatever it weighs maybe about
an eighth of that is actual meat because
yeah
the claws way the shell weighs something
like two but in the beginning i was an
idiot i was like i didn't know i was
gonna go to third i didn't plan this
ahead of time and i'm
dumping it in the butter and i'm like
yeah and by the end i'm just like
i i have to win and i won
i had 13 and a half he had 13.
interesting all right so you made all
this money then
when did you drop out of college you
dropped out right i did not drop down
finish college but i started the hedge
fund so i had made like 1.65 million i
started the hedge fund
senior year of college because i thought
that like oh i turned a few thousand to
a few million i can do anything
wrong right i'm really good at these
little patterns i'm
you know from 700 000 to 1.65 million i
actually short sold
because there were no more penny stock
breakouts in 2001 2002 they all
collapsed that's when the boiler rooms
were exposed so i
literally i made 700 000 in the first
four months of 2000
the last eight months i lost 10 000. so
it was very focused on these one
breakout pattern then i learned short
selling um
but then again i'm dealing with these
fast moving stocks and i'm taking like
10 000 shares 50 000 shares 30 000
shares
but it's not scalable i can never make
billions of dollars because these stocks
move too much there's too much slippage
each way
so i started the hedge fund and for
three years i was the number one ranked
hedge fund
you know for short selling making like
200 300 grand
per year but not doing much like i i
barely went to class i'm trying to like
take meetings
sometimes i would take a meeting and
miss class sometimes i would miss
uh you know a trade for like a meeting
and like i just you didn't like
in college yeah senior year why did you
start a hedge fund why not just keep
trading for yourself so
i wanted to take bigger amounts and i
didn't
have that much money like you know i
made 1.65 million but after taxes we're
talking like a million dollars basically
and i was like no i need to have like my
hedge fund only got up to like 3 million
but still it was like two million of
others who else who else invested how
did you find
family friends um you couldn't advertise
hedge funds back then so like
i didn't know what was your annual
return on the hedge fund so i was making
like 20
per year on like you know a two three
million dollar hedge fund which is
decent but it wasn't
like huge money given the small size of
the fund and then i made my fatal
mistake where i invested in my best
friend's dad's company i threw out my
trading rules
threw out all my risk and i was like
this guy invented print at home
ticketing which actually turned out to
be the right technology
the company later got bought for 80
million but before they got bought out
they went bankrupt and i lost
500 grand of my own money and all my
industry credibility and that was the
single
best lesson for me because now i've
never had a big loss since then because
i never want that terrible feeling again
yeah so you invested friends and
family's money what was that like to
tell them about a loss like hey guys you
lost
that was terrible i mean the hedge fund
still finished up over four years like
up like one percent on average even with
the loss because 20 gains but it was
it was just demoralizing did that did
that ruin any relationships
oh 100 ruin relationships credibility i
was also on this tv show wall street
warriors
so right as the tv show was airing my
fun lost and everyone's like oh he got
cocky being on tv
even though i was in this position
before the tv show they didn't
understand
but the tv show was a hit and so even
though i had this hedge fund which
it was basically break even after three
good years and one bad year no one was
asking for their money back but i saw an
opportunity because the tv show
everyone started asking how do i turn a
few thousand into a few million most
people who teach
how to make money on the internet are
full of crap right so i was like
ding let me talk about my gains let me
talk about my losses let me show
everything
so i went back to 12 grand the beginning
um my
roots 12 415 which is what's so crazy
i still can't get over that coincidence
that's messed up um i went back and i
started showing every trade
uh on my blog on timothysykes.com
showing videos
i would trade you know for a hundred
dollars like two hundred dollars the
press would rip on me because i'm like
now this reality tv star and they're
like
you obviously lost everything and i
didn't lose everything but i
specifically went back to my roots
because i wanted to show that i could
redo it
and there was a website back then called
covester which tapped into your
brokerage account
and you could show off what you did and
i quickly became the number one ranked
trader out of 60
000 traders the 12 grand got turned into
250 000 over three years not quite
the initial thing but again i'm making
blog posts video lessons
and just to be able to turn 12 000 into
250 000 is nice yeah
so you saw this as the new business that
instead of trading
you could just trade in conjunction with
teaching yeah i saw a huge need
just because i started getting 20 50 100
200 emails a day
i was like no one's teaching this stuff
how much how much were you making back
then
from teaching like what what did you
sell how much was it how much were you
making
um i mean i started out with one book i
thought it was gonna be a bestseller it
bombed
like you know um i had like tim alerts
it was like 30
a month i was making like five ten grand
a month um
you know it was a decent amount and then
from trading i was making like five ten
grand a month yeah um but then you know
teaching blossomed
where now i make millions from teaching
and now i'm able to donate all my
trading profits right
but but as you were going on the
internet because i remember you were
really prolific around i think it was
2004
five and six what were you doing on
those years because that's whoops
because that's when i found you
that was when the tv show was starting
to air okay and that was right when i
got into teaching
um and i had a market watch article that
said like i was like a wonderkind
um and again i didn't even know the
rules like once i had that five hundred
thousand dollar loss
that really solidified like rule number
one is complex as quickly
what did you learn about marketing when
you were doing that like how did you how
did
people find you beyond just seeing the
tv show yeah
um i mean i i like to speak i like to
talk
a lot um so i would call out a lot of
scams um
and you know i get in like a lot of
fights with like these like little
scammers and i was like here's 20
reasons why this company's a scam and
then that blog post would kind of go
viral
in the penny stock market it would be a
debate and i would always win
because it's not hard to judge if a
company is a scam it's harder to judge
when it's going to collapse
so i always had um you know a blog post
that would go viral or
get shared a lot now i have three
thousand plus blog posts on
timothysikes.com and they're all
they act as little breadcrumbs because
then i can point back i got in fights
with like rappers
rappers would steal my instagram photos
instagram was very big for me
one day i woke up little bow wow stole
one of my instagram photos
i used to post like how did he steal it
so i used to post like stacks of cash i
was like
marketing i think i was the first person
a business week ever used the term
in the title so i have that i'm a
pioneer so would you say an orange
lamborghini
so so you were the original i don't want
to say the tai lopez but like before tai
lopez
in what way i had an orange lamborghini
only
because they got the the black
lamborghini that i wanted sold at the
day before so
i embraced the orange lamborghini
lifestyle why did you want the orange
lamborghini in the first
so i did a test where um this is what's
so interesting so i'm
i'm learning just like how to grow my
business right
i did like a 45 minute in-depth video
like
really just going through this company's
sec filings digging through it
and like exposing it as a scam and i
posted and i was like i stayed up all
night and like
like 30 dorks like watched in they're
like good job tim right and i was like
there's more more people have to do this
i just got in the lamborghini because i
was in miami i was like screw it let me
like i'm
finding success i always wanted a nice
car so i started posting pictures of
lamborghini
on like instagram and on twitter and
like those posts would just blow up and
my little
technical analysis videos wouldn't so
then i got the bright idea to
merge them so i did put the same 45
minute video
but i put like a little 30 second
trailer of like my lamborghini in the
beginning and i was like if you want
this car
then you study this video so it was
literally like what was that
this was 2008 2009 so this was
2000 before tai lopez right tai lopez i
think was 2009 or
he was two thousand eight nine or ten so
you were before tyler yeah but i
so i did that and the two videos are the
exact same analysis as the stock
but with the orange lamborghini four
times as many people watched it and they
watch it three times longer
so i was like so i started posting cars
i got multiple cars i had like two
lamborghinis i had a rolls royce i had a
ferrari i've sold all my cars now i
don't need any of that crap but when i
was growing the business
the cars blew up and i would also take a
million dollars of cash
which they don't allow anymore and i
would put it posted on my bed like i
would spell like tim or sykes or
you know with 10 000 things like ultra i
don't think anybody's ever done that
right
and then i woke up one morning and bow
wow had taken my
stack of like a million dollars like
people don't have stacks of cash right
like this is fake money but i actually
had real money right
and he had filtered it and he wrote like
liquid cash or something
and everyone started tagging me because
he had just taken my picture yeah so
then i posted it like my picture versus
his picture and i was like bow wow like
why are you taking other people's cash
photos like i'll teach you the stock
market so you don't have to be a broke
rapper anymore
and you know you can have your own money
wow and i signed it little juju so like
i was like petty
and it blew up and it like this was
before the bow wow challenge where like
he faked
yeah so this was the first thing i was
like it was literally number one
trending on facebook
um like stock trader calls out rapper
right like they had like a little
section on that i was like yeah this is
cool like why not
then he wrote a post where he tagged me
on instagram he's like everyone go
attack timothy sykes and he linked me
and i started getting all these like
little l's and snake icons like that's
how you get attacked on instagram like i
don't feel attacked like this is
laughable and i literally got over 200
000 followers
overnight because of that and then there
were other rappers the game also did it
and
wow i just did that then i called out
the game we got on tmz i got another 200
000 followers i had to apologize to the
game so so it seems like you've taken
the approach that all publicity is good
publicity because i'm teaching something
that's real and an industry full of
scams
so for me i teach that 90 percent of
traders lose i teach that almost every
penny stock fails
so i'm the antithesis of jordan belford
who pumps up the bs
yeah so i just have to be real and i can
talk about this like if you think
that's fine i have several millionaire
students that don't even like me because
they're like no you're too aggressive
with your marketing but you taught me
everything i know
i'm fine with that so what's your
response then to the people who say
this is a scam uh this isn't legitimate
he's trying to sell something makes more
money teaching what what what is your
response
so i have 1500 videos now on my youtube
channel so if you watch these like i
have live trades student trades rules
video lessons
everything you can learn so much from my
youtube um my first millionaire student
michael good
i had this thing called the millionaire
challenge it's all my coaching all my
dvds all my webinars you get everything
and michael good said that i was a scam
and he wrote this blog post timothy
sykes is full of bs
and went back and forth i always listen
to like all my haters like i know you're
supposed to ignore them but i engaged
them so we went back and forth there's
63 comments
and he gave me a chance and literally he
thought that i was a scam but then i
converted him because i showed him what
i was doing and now he's made over two
million dollars he's my moderator in my
chat room
so i welcome the haters if i can turn my
haters into millionaires i can teach
anybody yeah
do you think the whole lamborghini thing
and the money still works today
um i'm sure it does i don't do it
anymore because now i've
proven like i have you know six
millionaire students now so i don't need
to do that
and frankly i think it's bad for the
environment i sold all my cars i don't
need any of that stuff
i focus on my charity so now i i've
converted because now
the cars thing was never really me i
just wanted to get students i
i always wanted nice cars but like i
went over the top like you know with a
million dollars you wanted the cars
no i wanted the cars but i didn't need
to like show them off like i posted
aggressively specifically to get more
students because i'm like if you want
these cars i wasn't like
yo i'm a rapper like i do have some
music videos which are terrible
but like you know you don't need to post
aggressively unless there's a reason and
my reason was i want to teach
and going back to that first video
recognizing what gets people to watch a
45 minute detailed video
you need some kind of reward so i
actually did a uh
a test ad i think this was like two and
a half years ago you remember this the
lamborghini
video so i had i i did a test for a
youtube video i had one
youtube ad where i sold the program with
a lamborghini in the background it was a
convertible yellow
lamborghini huracan yeah and then in the
other video was just me
sitting in my office and the lamborghini
video converted so much worse
than just me sitting in an office
without a lamborghini i think
i was probably very early in the game
and then it got duplicated because then
a lot of people like i bought my cars
a lot of people just rent them for the
day and then they became like fake ads
like
people use fake cash i actually went to
the bank i had business insider follow
me to the bank as i took out 1.2 million
we had like six security guards like
just being real but now it's so diluted
because so many people do it
and now it kind of loses itself so what
do you think the trick is for marketing
now
what do you think what works being as
authentic as possible if you can do a 45
minute video from start to finish
showing like
a trade and like how you you thought
about it like your thesis and your risk
reward
and then other you know students like
testimonials like real students
not fake testimonials there's people
like jim r says this like andrew f said
like i show all my real students they're
real people i go to their houses i go to
their weddings
um it's pretty cool so as real as you
can be but
i think you have to be an expert first
so many people want to get into like the
marketing game but they're not experts
you need to have some value i would not
be the teacher i am today without that
500 000
loss if i only taught how i made so much
money i would teach a very risky
strategy
that would be setting my students up for
failure but i've had the good and the
bad
and i've been on several reality shows
so i have thick skin so it doesn't even
matter
how long did it take for you to become
an expert in stock trading
um i mean i had the loss uh the big loss
was like seven years in
and i didn't really respect my risk
management so i would say like seven to
eight years where i really got risk
management but then once i
redid the 12k to 250k the second time
showing every trade and then sometimes
trading bigger now making a million
dollars this year
um i mean i'm 20 years in right now but
i think like six
seven eight years so if i can teach my
students
all in like one or two or three years i
can condense that
i can save them time i can speed up
their learning curve and what's your
annual rate of return
like on average over the 20 years i i
have no idea because now i
some years i go big some years i go
small um my whole goal is though to make
six figures in trading so it's not like
a percentage maybe 10
if you're trading with like how much do
you trade i mean i go back to 12 grand
every year but then i have a bigger
account sometimes with like three or
four hundred grand so
i would say like the 12 grand account
becomes like 60 70
sometimes 80 grand at the end of the
year because you can grow a small
account faster
and then the three or four hundred grand
becomes like a million at least that's
what it is
but you never publicize your your trades
but you do it after the fact no no i
show all my trades in real time that's
the cool thing so like
a lot of the time ahead of time i post
them so i post a watch list every night
i'm like
here are 10 stocks i'm gonna watch if
this stock breaks out or if the stock
has good earnings
i'll buy it so like i can actually
predict my trades ahead of time a lot of
my best students predict my trades
because i'm teaching patterns the trades
are just real-time examples of the
patterns that i teach
so i have like seven key patterns that i
teach and like
a lot of my students like when the stock
is setting up even if sometimes i'm not
in the chat room sometimes i don't see
it
but my students see it and they're like
it's a number five it's a psych number
five and like the chat room is like
where's sykes
and you're still you still use the same
strategy you're trading low cap stocks
low crap socks um i don't really short
sell that much anymore just because
even though it's effective my students
couldn't really do it because in order
to short sell these low price stocks you
have to find borrows it's very
complicated short selling like betting
on lower prices freaks a lot of people
out so even when i won
like students would be like now this
isn't for me so i've adapted not
necessarily to make the most money but
to be the best teacher
can we talk about donating can we talk
about can we talk about income for a
second or whatever you like cool
we'll just say how much how much do you
make oh she makes now
let's see let's just ask me no it varies
every year so this is why i'm so proud
to be able to donate
like a million dollars of trading profit
or i'm at like 9.50 so far okay this
year
um but income wise i think i'm at like
four or five million maybe six million
in
teaching so i can prioritize my students
so that's why like there's a lot of chat
rooms out there where they trade big and
like they don't donate their profits and
they're like oh
let me just focus on like making as much
money from trading i don't care about my
students with me
i teach the patterns i show all the
trades and it's like here
learn from this where do you where do
you invest and spend
all that extra money like let's say you
you a lot of it goes to tax four million
yes so let's say so on so you donate a
million let's just say
you have four million dollars left over
i actually dip into my pockets though
too so i usually donate about a million
five on average for the past three okay
and then after tax we'll say 40
on tax so that leaves you with one six
left leftover where does that go bank
account save up
for what i bought my parents a place
down in miami beach so that was nice
that was like one
one six one seven because i bought two
apartments next to each other um did you
buy them cash
um i don't even know i i gave it to you
know my financial guy and i was like
here like it's
it's all i don't i don't handle like my
my taxes i don't even do that like i'm
so focused on teaching
i have like and i now have a staff of
like 50 plus people and so i'm like do
this
whatever works you know like if you ask
me like my accounting
i have no idea i give it all to my
account so you don't pay too much
attention to
where all of your extra money is stored
like i mean it just goes into liquid
cash like i don't
i don't have any like mutual funds i
don't have any like long-term
investments
um i just don't i don't really believe
no real estate
it's like you're like rental my parents
place i i had like had a few places that
i was looking like rent to buy but like
i never really liked it i was always
traveling
all this like i've been doing this while
i've been traveling to 120 countries my
charities built 70 schools so like aside
from this year i've always been
traveling and focused on that
and i love the challenge of teaching
trading and traveling but what's the
reason why you never wanted to do like a
nest egg just say like you know what i
want six million bucks just invested it
in like a solid index fund
it's always gonna be there i'm just
gonna let it grow never touch it every
year i'll add another million to it
yeah i don't know i don't i really think
that the market
is overvalued um like real estate and
stock market i mean especially after an
11 year bull market so
i'm just kind of scared like i never
really you know had that much you have
to understand i'm focused on trading
so like for me it's like the challenge i
don't even spend that much like aside
from like the cars like
okay buying my parents stuff like
donating millions like i'm actually
i know it doesn't look like it but i'm
actually pretty frugal
i don't know but if you ask me what if
you ask me what time it is i'll check my
iphone
like this is where did you get that
watch this was uh earlier this year but
like
how much did it cost this was like 40
000. yeah but like aside from it
aside from a few things like that like i
really don't need that much like if i
let's say god forbid i lost everything
right i really wouldn't it wouldn't be
that bad like
i would actually like like the challenge
to try to get it back
like i i really just don't need it i've
had the luxury things they're nice
so you've had the confidence that no
matter what you're gonna make money
you're always gonna find a way to make
it happen so you don't really need
that correct bob you have to understand
like most people who teach on the
internet are so full of crap
so all i have to do is be real like my
video lessons about my losses get three
times the number of views
than my wins do because they're like no
one else talks in detail about their
losses
so i literally can't lose like if i
freaking win
okay i made some money i was right my
patterns work if i lose hopefully i cut
losses rule number one quickly and i
show that maybe sometimes i get
undisciplined i don't cut losses quickly
then that video gets even more views and
then i get more students like
it's just win win win win win it's
actually a pretty cool thing
just being real in an industry full of
scams okay well
i'm still a little confused on the fact
that you you said you
you keep everything in cash yes and you
have one property which
would be your parent's property yes is
that
cash all in one bank account no we have
a few it's dispersed
yeah jack wants to know the the log yeah
let me write it down
no i mean it's i like to stay liquid and
going with my trading strategy like
i stay liquid like i have zero stocks
right now overnight as the dow just
dropped like nearly a thousand today so
you're not invested in
anything zero all cash i like staying
liquid don't you feel though that you've
missed out on such a big run last like
six months 100
yeah but who cares so what i'm still
making nearly a million dollars in
trading profits you don't have to catch
every move
so many people have fomo fear of missing
out and they're like oh i have to catch
this i have to catch this
i stay liquid and i catch what i can i
guess it's different for me because i
like having that nest egg i
like seeing those numbers just grow
steady and if it dips down i think i put
like 50k into the market this morning
when it dipped down
yeah i've been buying everything every
hour it's a little bit lower but you
have to understand too like i don't
even act in terms of like what makes me
the most money like
if you look at my charitable giving like
it's i spend
i give way too much compared to my
income but for me
i do what works for me like i'm weird in
the head on
yeah swap out a battery yeah that was
that was still recording
i like the faces that you're making
though this is hilarious
they're just like you're like this guy's
so full like i don't know i don't think
so i don't think your face says that
though and that's why it's beautiful
oh i'm sorry no that's not what you
don't have to apologize i get this all
the time you have to understand i'm
in the head the way that i like think
about charity and income and stuff like
that so like
you're this is a psychology this is an
intervention i think thank you for doing
this
obviously like i want to go into
everything and do it with skepticism
because i feel like that's
doing justice to our viewers understand
i like the skepticism this is the
beautiful thing about being real
like people have all these conspiracy
theories like oh your dad trades for you
oh your charity is a tax haven
none of that is true i do all my own
trades i donate too much compared to my
income
you have my email from my accountant
saying like you're donating too much
so what would it okay wouldn't your
accountant advise
for you though to have some sort of
long-term investment of course they give
me all kinds of things and i say you
just say no
what's the point why do you have i want
that i want everything to be like
legal right like i want like if you if i
got audited if i had like
any tax issues like it's all it's all
done by the books what about when you're
older are you going to continue to be
doing this for the rest of your life
i mean i think that there's always going
to be scams in the market and i can
always expose the scams there's always
going to be small
okay so that's your that's your what do
you think is a scam no companies
companies companies okay
but no but like teachers yeah so if
anybody teaches in the stock market and
they don't show every trade
what are you teaching like i just don't
believe you there's so many people like
oh you show every single trading show
every trade
20 plus years income tax returns audits
like i show it all
so that you can see like you can see my
screw ups you can see my wins you can
see my losses i don't win every time i
win roughly two thirds of the time but
rule number one is i cut losses quickly
so my gains are a thousand two thousand
three thousand my losses are 300 200
400. so you're saying that basically you
have this
this very very um precise strategy that
you follow every single time
anything else out of it is outside of
your area of expertise and you just want
to focus on this very small
[ __ ] i say i trade like a sniper so i
take my my little shot
i take my one shot if there's a pattern
that fits what i teach i try to take it
and it's not an exact sciences how many
people get your alerts
when you say like i think this is going
to break out i got
i've got my watch list 10 stocks how
many people see that
um a few thousand like six thousand
seven thousand do you think that could
have any sort of impact on the price of
the stock
i mean i'm trading like the most active
penny stocks so they're trading 100 200
300 million so like i specifically don't
trade
like illiquid stocks and the interesting
thing about my students is
because i made like pretty much half my
money going long and half my money going
short
there's a whole division in the penny
stock world it's not like everyone buy a
one spot there are gurus like that and
they specifically push the price up
for me half my audience i would say even
more than half likes to short sell right
so like any stock that's up 100
they're like it's a scam so there's like
a battle in my chat room between the
short sellers
and like the buyers and that creates the
market yeah because my thought you
if you almost get like a five stock
watch list already people are gonna
start trickling in and i think if you
have let's say we'll just call it 5 000
people
you know they're telling their friends
but so 5 000 i bet is more like 12.
but you have to also understand so like
i have a lot of haters because like
like a lot of people think that i'm a
scam right so they see me buy a stock
and they're like this is a scam
it's a psych pump i'm gonna short it so
i have like this built-in audience of
people who like
go against me and i'm just like whatever
it doesn't even matter to me because if
i win i'm gonna make a video lesson if i
lose i'm gonna make a video lesson
and i'm just trying to win more than i
lose so i'm trying to let the patterns
do their thing everyone else has their
little conspiracy theories
i'm the guy who's been seeing this stuff
for 20 plus years also understand
i'm trading active stocks and the stocks
that i'm trading are usually already up
50 or 100
so they're they're on my radar because
they're a percent winner already i don't
just pick like a stock like oh
this has an interesting technology it's
done nothing for two years but now let
me buy it that's what penny stock
promoters do they get paid by the
companies for me i don't get paid by the
companies
i get paid by customers students who
want
accurate information so there's always
going to be a market for
accurate honest information and
recognizing the fact that i'm wrong a
third of the time
and then i just cut losses quickly if
you stay disciplined
trading is all about discipline right so
i'm basically like a drill sergeant
teaching these degenerate traders like
you have to do this i say trading is a
battlefield like you know the e-trade
baby
like the little dancing baby on the
commercials like look trading investing
is so easy
if it were realistic if you looked at
like the odds of like statistics of what
people actually do with 90
of traders losing 70 of investors
failing to beat the s p 500 every year
the baby would be bloody it would be
bruised it would be all blurred out on
tv
trading is a battlefield okay that baby
is ill-equipped
to be on this battlefield you don't
bring a baby on the battlefield that's
wrong but do you
think do you think the average person is
probably just better off with an index
fund instead of spending all the time
learning how to trade stocks yeah maybe
they're just better off here's an index
fund ride the market 100
if you have if you're fully loaded like
at work or you have like a family
i don't like most people who i meet like
very talented like photographers
videographers like should i get into and
i'm like no
you already have like a talent you
already have a passion this is for
people who are like kind of like oh i
have some extra time
um you know let me try something you
know people who otherwise would go to
like
uh the casino or something where the
odds are terrible like this is something
where
i think the odds can be in your favor if
you research enough and you put in
enough time but if you don't put in
enough time you're never going to get
good
can anyone do it if you put in enough
time
so you're saying can jack do it yeah
yeah okay
i you think i would be able to do it if
i could teach a homeless guy to freaking
do it if i could like clean up his like
theoretical drinking problem this
hypothetical exam you should
do that right you should you should do
that that would be incredible that would
be
an amazing it would be incredible go
viral but here's the thing
so i'm not looking to teach the most
number of people here's another layer
right
everyone else wants as many students as
possible like build my business i want
you know do the math like number of
subscribers paying this much
i don't want that for me i have the
opposite problem
i have everyone already hitting me up so
i've really toned down
on marketing i've toned down on a lot of
stuff because i'm looking for quality
over quantity
if i taught that homeless guy i would be
more overwhelmed and i have a problem
where i
answer dms i answer people's questions
and i'm overwhelmed
where's the problem in that if your goal
is to teach and get spread the awareness
if teaching of so much person but but
everything you have
but isn't that scalable everything you
do making the video to reach 10 people's
the same as reaching a million
sure your instagram gets blown up a
little bit more but you never respond
like i never respond to 99 of the dms
anyway
but i do and i feel guilty and i i take
this personally because you have to
understand i'm not just getting dm's
like hey i want to make money i'm
getting dms being like
i believed in this company i only read
your blog post after i lost 75
i'm devastated i feel for that person
even though i've never met them even
though i'll probably never meet them
with penny stocks i'm meeting constantly
people who have lost
half or all their money and it gets to
me because i have
the solution if i can you know if
there's the matrix if i could somehow
just
transfer everything that's in my head
into their head but wouldn't that be a
good deed though to
if you taught a homeless guy and that
that just went viral and then that got
tens of thousands more people
into the market wouldn't that just be a
net benefit even though you get hit up
more wouldn't that be
no 100 but the problem is most people
don't have the time they're not gonna
actually do what is required
because i'm not teaching exact science
so i can teach all my lessons but if
you're like yeah yeah i've seen like i
have 6 000 video lessons 6
800 video lessons right now right
because i'm basically a glorified
history teacher i'm teaching 20 years of
experience
every single person watching those video
lessons is playing catch up because they
haven't seen all the plays that i've
seen long and short
hot markets chinese hot stocks electric
vehicles stocks
crypto stocks weed stocks there's
different hot sectors so i'm trying to
teach history
and you have to go through all this
history a lot of people they're like
okay
if i've seen the chinese stock spiking
i've seen the weed stocks it's all the
same
no it's not there are nuances so it
doesn't matter how many people want to
do this
most people are unwilling to be as
dedicated
so i have newsletters where like okay
like you can you can learn and it's like
free
as you want like you know on my youtube
channel but again
you need to go above and beyond you
really the the biggest money is in the
smallest details
and most people just don't put in enough
time for that i would agree with that i
would say for anything you give a
hundred people the same thing and maybe
only a few of them will really use it
and be good at it
but i still think if you could teach
that person who's just like living out
of their car with
nothing but they have the motivation the
time the dedication
that would be huge and uh and have that
and make sure that person is completely
random and like like have to have a
third party
go and pick out the person yeah maybe we
eat like 10. you pick ten of them and
then you you have
whatever you look for the qualities in
the people that you think would be best
what if you have like different people
from different backgrounds and then you
see like
you know and i could turn into a whole
reality show really if i wanted to
i think that would be really interesting
that's cool but also understand 2020 is
so different than other years like the
pandemic like that's crazy
there's so much volatility this year so
if you let's say you dedicated
all of 2019 to learn there wasn't much
opportunity in my niche
so all the people who are doing the best
in 2020 are not students who signed up
in 2019
my best students right now are making
300 grand 500 grand a million but
they've been students for three or four
years they've seen slow markets so they
appreciate this
so you can't just judge every year like
what if you get started and there's a
slow year and then you get
you know disheartened like my top
student tim gratani has taken 1500 into
12.7 million
amazing he's like a robot but he made
nothing his first nine months while
working as a state farm insurance agent
can you study every night and make
nothing while you're living with your
parents
will you still stay dedicated most
people won't most people be like this is
a scam
after like three weeks or six weeks or
six months yeah
and why does your strategy not work with
higher
va like amounts of money i'm glad you
asked higher amounts of money and higher
priced stocks
um there's no real hedge funds there's
no real smart people in penny stocks
because the money just isn't
big enough like i'm one of like the
highest earning penny stock traders and
i've only made a few million
the biggest traders on wall street make
a few million in a day
they're trading you know forex they're
trading currencies they're trading
things that are more scalable and
they're using like prop firms and
goldman sachs money i'm using my own
money so it's a little different so i
say that i'm like fishing in my little
pond
and i think that this pond is great for
you know average people like with a few
thousand dollars i think there's too
many people with a few thousand dollars
that do just invest in an index fund and
like
if you have a ten thousand dollar
account like you might make what a
thousand two thousand dollars over the
year
which just to me doesn't move the needle
i think people with small accounts
should utilize their small account size
and take it as an
advantage because they can fish in the
pond if you have like a 50 million
dollar account you can't trade my
strategy i think if you have 10 grand
you invest the 10 000
but then you work to increase your
income so that way you have more money
that you could invest in an index fund
that's gonna give you
seven nine percent yeah i i mean again
like you can get rich off index funds
like in 50 70 years and buy a new
titanium hip you know like and
like put yourself in like the best old
age home ever and like eat caviar and
folks
every day when you're 90 as your teeth
are falling out and the nurses will make
it into the point
but the point is you save that money it
grows in the background
as you work to increase your income yeah
that's that's what that's what i'm
saying that's a responsible slow way of
getting rich over time and that's
fantastic
but you could get rich by increasing
like working and finding ways to
increase your income so that way you
just have more money to invest and you
could get
you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars invested again but if you learn
trading you can make a hundred thousand
dollars or two hundred thousand dollars
in a few weeks or months and that would
be
five years of an index but how much
money would you need to invest to make a
hundred thousand dollars in a few months
i mean some of these
these penny stocks go up i mean mass
companies apt went from four to forty in
like three days
um you know we have kodak even kodak
like got a loan from the government
which turned out to be all
questionable and that went from four to
fifty in three days like you're having
these crazy run-ups so let's say you buy
a thousand shares at four of kodak
you're not gonna sell that perfectly at
50 or 40
but you know you can go from 4 to 20 in
a day or two
that's this market and there are dozens
of examples like that right now but that
would still assume if you don't go all
in even if you do 20 of your portfolio
to do something like that you would
still need a thousand shares
twelve thousand dollars to do to do that
to make 100 think about this
let's say you have a ten thousand dollar
uh portfolio right you see kodak
you know that it's spiked up big in the
past you see the loan agreement you're
like okay let me buy a thousand shares
at four
you can either flip it at eight or ten
or twelve or twenty right you choose but
on your ten thousand dollar account you
might make
five grand six grand 10 grand 20 grand
in a day or two
and that kind of example has happened
dozens of times this year but i've also
seen some volatility nicola was a
perfect example people
got in and then just it got crushed or
the people who bought
especially calls wall street bets was a
fun one to watch during that time
because people were buying
nickel a call i don't do options but
yeah i was warning about nicola i
actually got in a fight i got blocked by
trevor nicola early on and i took that
as a badge of honor because i was like
no there's something sketchy here
and there is so that's one of them but
that that thing went from like what
three to like 90. right and even now
even after
all this sketchy stuff has happened it's
down to 20. yeah that's still even worth
20. because gm kind of backed them up
there's so much volatility that's what
you have to understand this time is
special
so index funds maybe in another time
like maybe if the market gets slow but
right now now you have all the new robin
hood
people you know they're getting three
million customers per month e-trade is
only getting 300
000. all the revenue people who they're
getting stimulus checks they're trading
with it
right so like you have so much
volatility in so many trades
i don't know how to ignore it that's
part of the reason why like i'm going
crazy this year where i'm just focused
specifically on trying to
capture as much opportunity not just for
the profits but for the education i say
people have two accounts their knowledge
account in their
brokerage account most people only want
to grow their brokerage account they
don't think about their knowledge
account
what is a knowledge account that's not
even a real thing but you have to grow
your knowledge enough
to be better prepared on every trade
most traders
are unprepared for trading like they
have their emotions
they don't have a specific plan they
don't have risk management so
they have lower odds of success on every
trade if you study if you paper trade
you don't even have to risk money like
while you're learning right like you can
use fantasy cash
you don't get the full emotional uh
education but at least you can learn the
volatility
and when you do that you start using
this volatility in your favor
the whole key here is using a small
account to your advantage
almost nobody in the world looks at a
small account as like i'm proud of my
two thousand dollar account
almost everyone on wall street will look
down on you i still get made fun of like
when i tweet like
made 1600 today made 1800 they're like
you've been doing this for like
20 years and you only make like a
thousand or two there's wall street
versus main street
wall street literally looks down on
people who make three thousand dollars
in a day
and i know most people that i know most
people on main street most
average retail traders would love to
make three thousand dollars in a day
so it's about taking the low-hanging
fruit realizing that it's a thousand two
thousand three thousand dollars in a day
and it can add up or 200 to 300 losses
what about the people who just follow
your trades they just see exactly
what you're doing as you pose be like
i'm gonna talk it on this and try to
sell at the same time so every day i
warn never follow my trades never follow
anybody's trades all my top students
they made money but they're
self-sufficient they don't need me so
for me i'm training wheels right so i'm
like
posting and i don't even just post like
my trades i post potential trades i'm
like if this stock
breaks above 330. i want people to
understand the whole game
never follow anybody else then you're
always dependent on them and that's how
frankly a lot of newsletters made why
does it matter if you're going to be
posting every single trade you do
because i don't want them to be
dependent on me what if i get hit by a
bus tomorrow then how are they going to
make money
look that might have just happened that
was crazy timing this is what i'm saying
this is all destiny what if i got hit
like they wouldn't know
i try to train my students to be
self-sufficient none of my top students
tune into my webinars
they've heard everything they know the
patterns inside and out this isn't
rocket science
it's freaking penny stocks pumping
themselves up and you're taking
advantage of hype and fear and
manipulation
how long does it take to learn
everything different markets different
times
like right now in 2020 this is an
amazing time to learn because you have
five 10 20 examples every day of
different like earnings winners
um scams being busted um you know
electric vehicle plays
potential vaccine plays there's so much
happening like by the end of the day
this is why i'm drinking coffee in any
energy like i need this stuff just to
freaking stay awake i'm gonna crash
after this interview
right i'm like a little kid bouncing up
and down and then i need money you only
have like
two switches what is just like a hundred
percent i think they want to just chris
yeah exactly
sometimes when i do a video like my
videographer will see like oh you're
done
like i'm just like hold on one second
let me swap out this battery
there's nothing in between that's funny
so what about your personal life then
you work a lot married to the job
how many hours a week do you work or a
day actually it's like 16 to 18 hours a
day
16 to 18. all work or you're taking
breaks throughout
i'll work i mean because i'm trading i'm
making video lessons i'm giving webinars
i'm writing blog posts i'm writing
tweets
doing instagram and then when the market
closes i do charity so i
manage like karma gala and save the
wreath these two accounts have
karma gal has 1.2 million followers save
the reef has 900
000 followers so i'm doing those posts
too because at night i want to try to
change the world so i have two jobs
so do you work 16 to 18 hours a week
every single day every week
per day yeah it's all right no days 18
hours a day every
yeah 100 of the week that's what it
takes if you truly want to get ahead
most people are unwilling to do it but
it's not work for me i love what i'm
doing i love teaching i love donating
i'm sick in the head
if i really just prioritize like my
money i wouldn't show my trades i
wouldn't teach i could probably make
more just by trading
but i actually love teaching others that
and doing like doing charts so here's
the thing not just donating money too
maybe i'll be the first person to say it
okay say whatever you like
okay this isn't about this is not about
i've heard everything
no you can't hurt me it's not what you
think so what i'm gonna say is like
i will i consider myself a hard worker
and i will
i will happily work 10 hours a day 11
hours a day
i'll go up to like 13 or 14 hours a day
yeah but the next day if i work like 14
hours one day
the next day i don't want to work more
than like 12.
you know like i i don't want to do like
two 14-hour days back-to-back yeah
like it's just like disappointed jack
like here's the deal i
like i said i'm fine working 10 hours 10
hours is good 11 hours is getting like
okay
it's a little annoying like i can do a
11 hour back to back obviously yeah but
if you're doing like 14 hours
and then 14 hours the next day and then
14 hours the next day it's just
like it am i just a wimp or is it just
like
i'm serious because like it just seems
unfeasible no to work 16 to 18 hours a
day
every single day of the week because i
see all these people like
all the tai lopez's people or like gary
vee's now like buster
and you got to work like all these hours
every single day of every single week
and it's like
and it never ends well i'm just like
wondering there's no end game
is he actually doing that much work so
because i i feel like i'm
i'm pretty maxed out like 14 hours a day
for me
it's not work because i love doing this
i'm teaching i'm also now some of my
students are teaching too so i'm helping
them launch teaching businesses because
now they can help me so i used to give
like four or five live webinars a week
now i'm down to one live webinar per
week because now my students give two to
four live webinars a week so i'm
actually getting help there
but i spend a lot of time on my charity
i don't just donate
one to one and a half million dollars of
trading profits i do a lot of spreading
awareness because i do believe that the
world has a lot of issues
and we are at this time in you know
human history
where we need to change the way we treat
the environment treat animals if you
follow karma gal or save the reef i'm
doing those posts because
it's not just about the money i could
donate a million i can donate a billion
and it wouldn't change anything we need
to change
millennials in the way that we're
treating like if literally
every single person watching this every
single person listening to this picks up
one piece of trash per day
it seems small but you're saving
millions of animals one piece of trash
one piece of plastic
stays forever and it kills multiple
animals we don't even think about that
we never even had a plastic problem
40 50 70 years ago now the plastic
problem is getting worse during the
pandemic
so i see these problems so for me i like
teaching but then i see a lot of other
issues like when i got started traveling
all i wanted to do was build schools but
schools take decades to really see the
impact on the community
a lot of places don't have decades a lot
of things like we did a documentary
in my spare time i filmed documentaries
too we did a documentary on the rhino
rhino are gonna be extinct in the next
five or ten years unless something is
done
rhino are getting killed for their horns
their horns people think that they're
made out of
you know these medicinal properties
there's nothing it's literally just
keratin in our fingernails
in the rhino horn so to me that's part
of the whole
misinformation out there i teach penny
stocks i teach how they're scams
i expose a lot of the bs when i see
rhinos and if you've ever seen a rhino
in person have you seen a rhino in
person
probably at the zoo san diego zoo would
probably be the only place that's cool
but they're beautiful and they're going
extinct due to misinformation where
people
get them because they think that they're
aphrodisiacs they're gonna cure cancer
they don't do any of that
it's literally just keratin in our
fingernails and we need to get that
information out there so i'm using
social media for that too
so i'm driven it's not about the money
if you look at the way that i work
i mean i work slave hours i probably am
underpaid
but i do what i love it's not just about
the pay once you reach a certain level i
bought my parents their own place
i donate millions of charity i want to
donate more but then you have to have
passion you have to love what you do
right i'm not i'm not saying it's about
the money or anything because a lot of
the work i do
like i literally just do it yeah because
like there's there's nothing
really honestly a lot of the times where
i can see any like
outcome of a lot of the work i do like
when i was always reaching out to like
all these people like i'm constantly
just like reaching out to random people
trying to network
right like i don't really see anything
come out of that but all i'm saying is
like
working 16 to 18 hour days every single
day
what do you think about this grant like
is that something
that's sustainable if even sustained
like like
a like you can do that in the first
place i like it see i like doing it i
don't know how long it could do
18 hours
initially i was doing from about eight
o'clock in the morning to about
i don't know 10 p.m at night i loved it
i had so much fun doing that that's
right
i couldn't do that good fourteen i
couldn't do that forever though i i
figured that like
35 through like mid 30s would probably
be a point where it would be like i know
i could scale back a little bit but i
loved it
but i just found one is good but 16 to
18. if we're just if we're saying you're
working 18 hours a day okay
say we wake up okay what time you wake
up seven six seven
okay wake up at six okay and then
depending on the time zone
but yes okay six o'clock right and then
when do you have breakfast right
i mean pretty much right away depending
on when my mom makes it if i'm home okay
so then at 6 30.
okay and you have yet to start work okay
brush teeth shower get all that stuff
done yeah maybe it's seven
yeah okay seven work starts yeah okay 18
hours
past seven right that's five
that's nine p.m i mean really so it's
mob
maybe even 19 hours it's when it's 10
p.m but sometimes i'm up till 11
sometimes
until midnight i don't look at the hours
i see stuff that has to get done
if people send me a video on like
plastic if there's like some you know we
just found
actually like a huge um coral reef
that's bigger than the
empire state building last night i was
up till like midnight writing the post
about that because it was a
fantastic find i don't think about the
hours i think about stuff that has to
get done
i do a watch list every night i do video
lessons every night i'm trying to launch
my students i'm trying to do a bunch of
things
wait no no we did the math wrong yeah at
1am
okay so you you start at 7am and then
obviously you're going to have to have
lunch you're going to have to have
dinner and then
i guess it's just quick that's that's
not even like a i mean i eat standing up
yeah like
yeah okay one am yeah to one am and then
you're waking up the next day at six
again
because i love what i do i jump out of
bed although granted
i use energy drinks and coffee which i
never had to do two years ago so maybe
i'm fading too and i don't even realize
it
i mean i get it 18 hours i get it yeah
yeah
sometimes you get so much in the zone
that you just you don't even want to go
to bed
and then you wake up in the morning and
you're so hyped i just starting
that that's the energy i i understand i
understand that as well like i get it
right like
obviously i have worked more than 14
hour days of my life but
i'm saying like my average being between
like 10 and 14. if i do more than that
like the next day i'm obliterated yeah i
it's
i i mean in the beginning when i first
got started stock trading i couldn't
even make it watching the market the
whole day i would like take a nap
because like when you're watching these
things go up and down like your head is
getting like screwed up
like in the beginning you had to build
up your tolerance at least i did
but again for me it's not just the stock
market when the stock market closes then
it's the charity and i'm very proud that
our charity has better
engagement than greenpeace and peta
times five
and you know what is it it's like my
money and this is like charity merch
this is made out of plastic
recycled water bottles which is pretty
cool so we're creating charity merch
we're trying to spread awareness we're
trying to donate
i'm wearing a lot of hats you know is
that cherry do you do anything to relax
what is this word is that a latin relay
i've heard yeah somebody was trying to
say there was a
i think it was like a friendship yeah i
don't know day oath
like a like an egg dish i don't know oh
i don't know i've never heard of it yeah
die off i don't know i don't know no i
have
goals i have a mission i love what i'm
doing you have to understand ninety
percent of traders lose i can save them
have you seen i am legend with will
smith and he's trying like the zombies
are coming in
and he's like i can save you i have the
cure and they're not listening because
they're zombies
that's how i feel i am will smith and i
am legend and the zombies are pounding
down my door
they're losing on trades the zombies are
losing they're losing everything they
basically are they're financial zombies
and i am will smith and i have the cure
for them
how do i keep that to myself that would
be selfish i
commend you on your energy like i think
that is
just i think i think it's incredible
because if i was getting six hours of
sleep every night
the next day i would just how much i
could get done but it's not even
energy it's when you find your mission
when you find your life goal you don't
think about the hours you think about
what you want to do
when i first got started teaching penny
stocks every financial expert i wrote to
them i
like i did like handwritten notes for my
book like a stupid guy like i got no
responses
i got a few responses every response
from financial experts don't do this
penny stocks are dangerous you can't
teach any that just made me more vote
motivated to teach
because i did this on my own what about
lawsuits let's just say because it is a
high-risk environment where people can
lose money yeah have you been the
subject of any lawsuits of students
being like i lost money no
rule number one is cut losses quickly if
anybody ever loses big they're breaking
my rules
so i teach so conservatively i have a
whole dvd where i talk in a high-pitched
voice i'm like i'm a castrated choir boy
this is how i trade i have no balls
i literally talk like this for an hour i
make such crazy analogies because i tell
you
that you have to be a castrated girl
you're very good at this it's
i'm telling you i've done a dvd like
this
mickey mouse correct that's how i teach
i trade
so conservatively i see these stocks
spike 200 300
and i'm taking 10 15 percent i'm like
it's a scam i don't know what's going to
go on
and i leave all this money on the table
and that's fine as i've shown you can
still make millions by taking
little tiny gains and playing it so
safely
let's talk about something other than
work
okay how about relationships yeah do you
have a girlfriend or a wife no
married to my job always is that always
gonna be the case
i don't know we'll see i don't know how
long affection
i have affection from my job it's
literally being married to the job have
you heard the phrase like married to the
job
i i am the definition of married to the
job um it's not a job for me it's a
mission okay but do you think at some
point in the future your priorities are
going to change hopefully hopefully i
can teach enough people
i first got started into teaching
because i thought oh if i teach
everybody these patterns
everyone will use them and they'll be
obliterated and i'll be free
these patterns have kind of been the
gift in the curse i missed my college
graduation
for a trade unfortunately as i said half
my students like to go long half my
students like to go short
so it's just a war and i've like started
it so you'll keep going until everyone
uses it and then it's ineffective and
you think that's my
that's my cue so it will be ineffective
once everyone starts to use it i hope
but unfortunately again even though i
have thousands of students what probably
like 300 of them actually pay attention
to all the rules in the video lessons
like
i'm teaching the freaking zombies that
and i am legend like that's what they
are okay what
are the hyenas in the lion king what
trade did you make this morning
uh i made five trades this morning i had
a morning spike on
sfor um i bought astc they have um
uh mass detection um or breath um
detection where
you can literally test your breath and
see if someone has
those were my morning trades um but then
in the afternoon
uh i had one right before the close what
was it
i only made 1700 today oh i lost on
b-a-n-t i lost 69 dollars on my last
trade today
69 yeah on the last year yeah
so you've made about 1600 today 1700 i
was in
training um all the positions were like
five or ten thousand i wasn't trading
big today because when the market is
down so much so i'm making so you made
like ten percent twenty percent well
like eight percent on like a few like i
was correct
i traded b-a-n-t twice i bought the
breakout i was right on that
and then i tried to go for the afternoon
breakout and it failed and i covered
what's the volume like on those stocks
bnt traded i don't know 400 500 million
shares i'm trading the most active penny
stocks yeah because they always have how
much was that
b-a-n-t yeah um like half a penny a
share i have a penny yeah some people's
i don't even like stuff pennies but
they're hot lately so
and what did it close at what did you
sell so
my first one i bought it at uh literally
a half a penny point zero
does it stop um so i i bought b-a-n-t at
.005
this morning and sold it at zero five
seven
so i made like twelve percent thirteen
percent um it was like six hundred fifty
bucks and then in the afternoon
i bought it on the breakout at point
zero zero six
eight and i sold it at point zero zero
six five i lost
one one third of a penny i don't
normally trade sell penny stocks
it's crazy trying to like fit in like a
third of a penny but that's what's hot
it was still up like 100
on the day and if you're so certain in
all the trades that you do
why not i'm not certain on any trade i
can lose on any trade i always say cut
losses quickly
in any one trade so why don't use
leverage why i don't go all in
because i'm never certain i'm the
opposite of certain
i have ideas where i think this stock
can run i think this stock can break out
but i can be proven wrong
i mean if you're so if i'm sure that
i'll make profits 70
of the time yeah i would do i would
probably put in
a fifth a tenth of my net worth and just
do that over and over you don't know
you don't know which ones like i i'm
surprised sometimes that the ones that
work out like i take speculative plays
sometimes like
dgly they make body cameras for police
people and you know if we have civil
unrest then theoretically the police
need
equipment so dgly spikes whenever
there's riots or protests
i'm always shocked at how much that runs
and i usually take profits too quickly
so if i had like you know if i wasn't
emotional if i could just say okay dgly
runs a lot then i would be more
aggressive on that one because i usually
underestimate it
but because this isn't an exact science
sometimes there's civil unrest sometimes
there's a protest and dgly does not run
it's not an exact science right but of
course you wouldn't be teaching
something that if you weren't at least
more than likely sure that you were
going to make money you wouldn't
like sell courses on that right yeah so
if you are
okay maybe not not the word certain
but fairly sure that you're going to
make profits on 70
of trades why not be buying short-term
calls and leveraging there's no options
on these on these stocks there's
okay that was that was but i wouldn't
use leverage i wouldn't use all in
because again for me it's not how much i
can make on the trade it's how to teach
i don't want to teach my students to go
all in i don't want to teach my students
to use leverage i'm trying to put myself
in the position
of a student who's just beginning this
is why i put like it's laughable that
like a multi-millionaire puts in five or
ten thousand dollars into a trade
it cost me literally a few hundred
dollars to send out the text messages
and the emails like
it's not specifically to make money i
make money in this business my teaching
business grows
because i don't have the cancels that
other people have because i'm real
my job is to create the most successful
students so if i go all in or let's say
i'm saying i'm tired of trading with
five or ten thousand let me put in a
hundred thousand
students cancel because they are not
learning how they should be
trading and even if they don't cancel
they're not successful
what if i say oh seventy percent of the
time let me just go bigger
and then my students start doing it but
then they're not trained and then they
lose big
so i'm not just trading for myself i'm
trading
as a student and i don't want to teach
my students the wrong way
does that make sense so what advice do
you have for graham and i
um just in general build your youtube
channel keep going let's see what you
can go all right
i think this is fantastic you guys have
a great niche you guys ask great
questions
there's demand for it you know you have
value and you know you can do this here
like
i'm excited to see what you guys can do
cutting through the bs
always just be real and go into all the
numbers that's why i like when
interviews they're like
can i ask any question like yeah be real
and go into all the details because most
people won't
most people have stuff to hide if you
can be real on the internet
the internet is yours jack wanted to
know your net worth
oh yeah can you say it yeah like 20 to
25 million
it's pretty good jack is mildly
impressed but it doesn't matter who
cares
but again if i lost everything i would
be fine it would actually be a fanta i
don't know how i would lose everything
if you're looking for a place to lose
that money
yeah i'm sure that there are plenty of
people that would be willing to
jack wants it except large amounts of
money
jack was gonna ask you also for a
million dollars i wasn't kidding
but i'm kidding i don't i don't loan
money out to people um but i do donate
to charities so if you know any
charities if
people watching this know any charities
i'm always looking for new causes like
building schools helping animals helping
the environment we just did nami
the national alliance on mental illness
yeah this is
usually uh under a prioritized issue
what's your favorite
i mean i'm all about education so we
built something we're talking about
pokemon cards
yeah that's your favorite which favorite
pokemon card oh
yeah no i was joking i don't do pokemon
cards i know you did that with like
logan yeah yeah
you know logan is actually in like
kansas with like one of my friends
his family owns like a card shop and so
he's like doing a whole new thing oh
cool with like
i guess there's like a two million
dollar card or something i don't know oh
the uh
illustrator pikachu yeah yeah so that's
in kansas yeah
so your advice for graham is that he
should to con uh he should continue
growing his youtube channel 100 you
don't know very much about me but what
would your advice be from me
stay by grant stay by grant
learn from those who are successful
learn from those who are like creating a
new path
and then find your own angle too like
i'm not saying like you have to be like
grant
but you know you could literally do
you're in the vicinity and you can learn
from this and then you can start saying
oh i'm actually better at this
so a lot of my students like they start
learning from me but then they
mold their strategy we can't let jack
get too good though because then he's
going to go off and start his own thing
so
we probably gonna we gotta we gotta cage
him a little bit you have to cage
yeah cage him a little bit we wanted to
get good but not too good no it's
probably inevitable
i hate to tell you because he's he's
asking your questions uh now
but you guys can work stop asking good
questions yeah
invest in his business and then you know
you can grow your net worth and you grow
your business by investing in him
that's how it be like i love the fact
that i like this guy
i like him she's a good guy she just
said it it was going good
up until then i usually stick my foot in
the mouth at a certain time
an hour 16 i mean it usually is like
within like 30 minutes so
i've lasted longer no you learn from
successful people you see what works
and then you find what works best for
you and then you try to create a circle
of successful people
so i'm very proud that my students are
now teaching even though they have
slightly different patterns than mine
fantastic i can only do so much as you
say like the whole 16 18 hours freaks
you out right
so now i have students who are doing the
work and i'm like asking them sometimes
like hey make a video lesson on this
trade
and they do like a 45 minute video 45
minutes i didn't have
so it's good to have helpers it's good
to create like a whole circle of success
that makes sense i think that's a that's
a good
that's a good quality statement to
unders to truly understand
that one size does not fit all yeah
right like everyone has their own
strategies
what i've noticed is that some other
people would be so convinced
that so i'd loosely loosely trade
options or
lightly trade options like i'm not super
into the rabbit hole right
but yeah of course but i've talked to
plenty of people and they're like
oh my option strategy is they think it's
the best right everyone thinks their
option strategy is the best until they
lose everything right right but like
i i'm fairly confident in my strategy
and when i try to talk to other people
about it like i always say like never
develop your own strategy right because
if someone were to copy my
strategy like exactly like they would
lose everything
they don't know they don't understand
like my thought process that goes along
with my strategy because
i've adapted my strategy to fit what i
know
like about myself and everyone everyone
should learn from somebody who's
successful but then tailor it to
yourself this is what i say to all my
students like i'll teach you what's
worked for me
then you choose a strategy do you like
going short selling do you like buying
breakouts do you like holding for a
minute do you like holding for an hour i
have this one student tim lento
he just says oh these stocks are scams
let me just short them and hold them for
months
and he does and he's made 700 grand i
try to hold it for like two or three
days
and the stock isn't budging and i'm like
freaking myself out i'm like psyching
myself out i don't have that patience
so even though they're scams even though
they are going to collapse eventually
it takes a certain mindset and you know
strengths and weaknesses
to do that so you just have to accept
that that's the market that's any market
that's money making in particular that's
why people watching this like
you try to do exactly what graham does
it might not work exactly for you but
take
bits and pieces from what he's doing and
then implement that
you know because obviously he's doing a
lot of successful stuff then you try
that too
and you're like oh this actually like
helps me speed up my learning curve
that's all you can do is speed up
people's learning curves and speed up
their
their little you know wealth curves a
little bit but the people still have to
do it themselves they can't just
say oh i'm just going to copy somebody
else it doesn't work that way well said
do you have any questions for grammar
eye
no well thank you so much for coming
good i wish i did is there anything else
that you wanted to say
i think i said pretty much everything
like five times over just find what you
love
do what you love it's not just about how
much money you make donate to charity
think about the world too
this is one thing that i would like to
stress where it doesn't matter how rich
you get if we lose
the earth if we lose the environment if
we lose our wildlife it's all
interconnected
i highly encourage you to watch david
attenborough's new movie on netflix um
what is it a
life on this is that the guy who does
the voice yeah he's the voice and he has
a new one
and it's he's been documenting the
wildlife and the environment and he sees
how it's all disappearing
and it's gonna you know lead to a lot of
repercussions and consequences over the
next few years so
as much as you want to focus on your own
wealth in your own future
it doesn't work unless we start thinking
about everybody else too and that's
something that's so urgent in the next
five ten
fifteen years with plastic with too many
animals with
so many different things and it's you
know if everyone does just a little bit
i'm not saying like everyone has to like
give up everything but i think if we all
start doing little things it makes a big
change
i like it cool how many cars do you have
zero i sold them all what about how many
credit cards do you have
like five or six how much money do you
have in your wallet
this is rapid fire and then what's your
credit what's your game what's your
credit score i have no idea
i don't i don't need to borrow we should
ask everyone from now on what's in your
wallet
yeah that's a great so i got i'm
superstitious i got my two two dollar
bills okay
and i got um lima rupia
i got some yen um another lima rupiah
rupiah this is just leftover cashew yes
no no this is just from like my last
trip
uh i was in turkey this is turkey and
then i got uh like what
five six twenty six hundred twenty bucks
wow
that kind of thing it's pretty good i
don't know i mean it's just whatever's
in my wallet
so and then if you want to take this as
a souvenir it's up to you
okay i literally so like i have my cash
photos and i actually did go to the bank
and i got the cash out i don't use fake
cash
i don't like fake cash there's a whole
conspiracy theory like sykes has no cash
you can just get a
a bundle of a million dollars off ebay
and it's like but i literally went to
the bank bank of america and i set it
all up and it was a
but these make really great coasters
they do
it's cool it's perfect thanks for having
me on girls thanks so much for coming on
this has been fun
it's good to do what what two do you
believe is this
three this is three yeah this is the few
jubilees we'll see
the next one second or third jubilee
we've done together so we'll see for the
fourth
yeah we'll keep going so with that said
you guys thank you so much for watching
really appreciate it we'll link to all
of our information down below in the
description
make sure to subscribe hit the
notification bell get your free stocks
from weeble
join the mentorship group and uh thank
you so much
thank you so much for watching print it
perfect
so do you have a jewish mom too i do
have a jewish mom she makes amazing good
sandwiches every day
jewish mothers yeah and so i go back
like i was in florida look at this i'll
actually show you
i take this as a badge of honor too does
your mom make sandwiches for you
kind of kind of not anymore
how old are you 22. well i'm double your
age and i still get sandwiches
so this is this is literally my text
this is funny and so i had problems with
like tv failed to connect
but like look so i'm like i was staying
there you just text your mom breakfast
yeah yeah look breakfast
look i say breakfast and then she says
like
perfect timing eight minutes groovy
breakfast coffee
what's the wi-fi are those demands
no they're just requests breakfast let's
see
look at his text to his mom breakfast
you see i didn't even wake up like this
was at like 5 47 i was like breath god i
wish the people
this is dinner this is awesome i'm a
mama's boy i admit it that's cool hey
i'm a total
parent's child as well and when i go
home like my mom likes to take care of
me like i'm an only child so like she
feels like a mom so like i'm doing her a
favor too but i'm also getting that's
good stuff all right so
so we have all the guests introduce the
podcast you got to say
welcome to the iced coffee hour my name
is timothy sykes
oh wait what what episode are we on the
25th 25th yeah so you have to say
welcome to the 25th
ever episode of the iced coffee hour
my name is timothy sykes and so far we
have made twelve thousand
four hundred and eighteen dollars just
say twelve thousand four hundred dollars
i think it's good what that's where
that's on cat adsense
are you serious because literally that's
what i started with i thought you were
like saying my
i started with twelve thousand four
hundred fifteen dollars i was like no
it's four fifteen oh well you'll know
that then just just say the number you
start with
crazy let's go wait which camera do i
look like uh whichever
look into this this is the okay yeah
that one that's
twelve thousand four hundred fifteen are
you serious that exact number yeah
four eighteen literally i started with
in four fifteen this is in my bio this
is everywhere
that's twelve thousand four hundred
fifteen dollars this is destiny yeah
this is
beautiful cool all right you got it down
25th ever episode
ever and we've made or you've made uh
just say we've
yeah we're all part of it yeah this is
the iced
coffee hour cool ready let's go